hey guys today it is the second of
November my name is Jess McDonald and
here's the important things that happen
in gaming to end call of duty black ops
3 will be getting mod tools on PC next
year Treyarch announced in a blog post
that the feature has been highly
requested from players and now they're
keen to help you create your own maps
modes and other unspecified content for
the new game Treyarch have said they're
planning to offer an open beta for the
mod tools at some point in the future
they added the beam ten to release
unranked dedicated server files
alongside the modding tools so you can
run your own servers with modded content
and there you'll be able to find and
joint service that feature mods through
an unranked server browser another code
news the campaign director of black ops
3 has explained that they've not
included the game's campaign on last gen
because the power of last generations of
machines was not enough to deliver on
their vision for the game which could
mean about a million different things
you walk after movie pictures and info
lambda today and here's all the good
stuff Blizzard Entertainment has
announced that the first official
trailer for the film is set to land this
friday which coincides with the first
day of blizzards annual blizzcon event a
new poster has also been released
displaying the Horde versus Alliance
theme with the characters Durotan and
Lothar Empire Magazine have also
published a few new exclusive shots of
the movies primary characters lotha der
attend and do hammer Warcraft a drought
on jun 10 of next year miley EA has
given us a taste of what we can expect
in the star wars battlefront in DLC Part
II a coo peter moore explained in a
recent earnings presentation what we've
announced is for extra packs over the
next 12 to 18 months coming post launch
you'll see new universes you're gonna
see you player actions obviously new
weaponry as well the fifty-dollar DLC
path also provides access to the new
content two weeks before everyone else
EA has said they'll be announcing more
specific details regarding the content
of battlefront 2 DLC
coming weeks the game is set to hit
shelves on November 17 let me know down
in that comment section what kind of
mods you'd like to see comes a call of
duty black ops 3 you can add a game
start we've got stories on all out for
leaks a plenty and the Xbox one
dashboard update that is everything I
want to tell you about today as always
let me know what mattered to you and I
will catch you again tomorrow